ma que moi j'étais très ému parce que
quand j'ai vu les images parce que sur
très violente
pour lui c'est pas qu'halfen villiers du
tout moi ça m'arrive et à 3 jours à
châtelet sujet à 2 en traitant d'hp et
dpd vous sentez que le gars marges et à
vous et vous vous dites juste comment ça
va se terminer
ça se termine qu'ils ont fini par se
retourner et partir mais après ce que je
veux dire et c'est totalement interdit
donc de le dire quand même mais m'est
interdit de goulens l'everest vous
voulez des rediffusions partie
s'interdit pas l'enlever on est en
direct
non mais dites nous sommes depuis oui
depuis un certain temps je vis avec
quelque chose d'alarmé à une arme sur
moi tout le temps tout en tout temps
tout le temps mais pas dans une
boulangerie moi c'est mon nom mais voilà
je pensais pas que ça arriverait un jour
je pensais pas qu'un jour tu atteindre
soir j'aurai une arme à la ceinture
comme comme un flic ou comme un à un
délinquant et je crois vous avez peur
aujourd'hui où sont maintenant menacés
de les deux là s'ils s'étaient retournés
qu'est ce que je fais je sais me battre
je fais quoi [ __ ] est de pda ce moment
mais c'est vrai quand on dit alors que
vous prenez des cours de self défense
sépare c'est pas une blague c'est vrai
il flippe à mort mon match et en ce
moment ça arrive mais ça arrive tout le
temps maintenant dans les chauffeurs
rubber partout tout le temps des grandes
quelque part c'est compliqué donc pardon
filmé la scène deux garçons elle est
très violente quand tu vois trois quatre
personnes qui arrivent sur toi
c'est très violent tu peux pas te
défendre casse toi sale guettait un
guet-apens le retrait d ici je ne
pensais pas un jour vivre dans ce monde
moi je veux je pensais pas être armé un
jour tous les jours et parfois je me
laisse juste peut-être arrêter la télé
un petit moment peut-être pour prendre
un peu de recul avec tout ça parce que
c'est et je parle d'agressions
homophobes d'agressions racistes
d'agressions antisémites envers de
parler c'est quand même on se fait avoir
compliqué non mais bon alors voilà
non mais mathieu je sais que tu es en
souffrance en ce moment tu sais que
alors je rappe je préfère la police j'ai
pas un beretta sur moi je donne parce
qu'il y avait bien sûr c'est pas mais
les ai tout le temps quelque chose on
prend votre souffrance mais c'est pas
voilà je suis parano quand je demande
leur jeu mais la manne amapola maisons
touchées l'armée non mais de redonner
leur appui c'est bon non mais non mais
je vous dise et c'est pas la solution et
je pense que oui je comprends votre
souffrance mais voilà tous les jeunes
qui nous regardent c'est pas la bonne
solution de voilà de ce peu de ce procès
bien servi il faut pas le dire et c'est
interdit dans deux fois c'est qu'il faut
pas le faire et
il a été très peu se retourner contre
vous et au contraire je pense que c'est
vraiment une vraie connerie est battu et
j'ai plein il ya plein de messages de
soutien pour vous très gentil mathieu
vraiment c'est vrai que là je vous sens
tous émus mathieu enfin comme est ce que
vous le sentez vous le mine de rien le
mal-être de mathieu en ce moment où on
lit brumath monde on voulait pas en
parler des séries que mathieu toi là tu
as envie d'en parler à nos
téléspectateurs et c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment on le son c'est vrai que tu
allais je dis la vérité - t'as des oat à
10 bat est un peu voilà tu es un peu
tout feu tout flamme ne croyez pas que
c'est parce que mathieu voilà devient
fou et c'est mathieu en ce moment il est
un des paramètres ça on va dire voilà
c'est ça oui mais j'adore venir ici un
ces deux heures on voit ces deux
secousses rigole et du coup chez apple
quand on a un acte on est mature qui
convoie dans la souffrance
ça fait beaucoup de peine parce que
c'est un gars soient absolument charmant
et eux et il faudrait que les gens se
rendent compte de ce qu'ils font voilà
hong hong et je voudrais rappeler juste
un truc l'homophobie le racisme
l'antisémitisme se sont pas des opinions
sont dit qu'on peut qu'ils sont
punissables et on va en prison pour ça
et au moins j'ai vu un garçon l'année
dernière qui était tout le temps
souriant tout le temps va vraiment tout
le temps au top et mais cette année un
garçon qui est à fleur de peau mais très
émotif et sûreté palmer et qui a peur
mais brauner du monde sait que qui a
peur est beau c'est que à chaque fois
que tu appelles que répond à ça moi je
vois un texto à kelly répond et que
l'addition argent via texto à
jean-michel et g10 coucouche j'ai pas
trop le moral si t'as pas d'idées il m'a
dit j'ai dû tout de suite je t'aime et
gtdi les gélules ya des soirs de juste
faire ta bande à l'écart est en revanche
très très présente gilles également
aussi bord isabelle qui m'aurait texto
hier donc ça en revanche les imbéciles
qui disent que la télé c'est que de la
télé dont les gens sont très présents au
tour de bras jean-mi toits qu'il était
quand même un des meilleurs potes de
mathieu parce que c'est vrai que y'a
liège qui a fait de nous faire son
témoignage c'est vrai que mathieu est
et le témoignage de match aussi les
poignantes sûr que lier ça touche
beaucoup ce que ton bien sûr ça me
touche beaucoup
c'est c'est malheureusement ce que le
bouche bée post une impression liesse si
tu vois tu es là j'ai l'impression que
tu es passé au dessus de ça maintenant
que michael est dans une phase où
vraiment il est dans la souffrance
toi j'ai l'impression que le combat est
passé est passé au-delà de ça maintenant
militant bahaa faut savoir déjà
aujourd'hui je suis sous anxiolytiques
et voilà malheureusement est bon pour
moi je suis dans mon droit nous sommes
en france bien sûr
voilà avait porté plainte c'est aux
homophobes de se cacher c'est eux qui
doivent avoir honte de ce qu'ils font
faut pas la peur change de camp parce
qu'on les traite de tous tout le temps
qu'a fait ensuite marche aux
antidépresseurs toute notre vie c'est
pas possible
le jean michel je te parlais dans un
instant parce que c'est vrai que tu
étais le plus proche de la nature
bah je vois tu ressens les choses ma
joue joue l on se voit encore tout à
l'heure après après l'émission parce que
c'est vrai que je vois bien qu'il a
besoin de soutiens extérieurs ce qui est
terrible dans dans ce qu'il dit c'est
que après tout prend des portions c'est
que même des choses qui pourraient être
anodine et qui ne sont peut-être pas des
choses qui vont se terminer en insultant
agressons il le prend comme si ça allait
devenir la suite je n'ai pas comparé à
nos essais nous bien il devient
complètement fou de se dire qu'il est
tout le temps en danger et c est vrai
mais qui dérange à fleur de peau avant
le mois de parfois j'essaie de le faire
blague extra mais dès que je dis un truc
qui me concerne ou même qui me concerne
moi dans ma vie il pleure à ma place il
peur plus que moi de choses que je dis
il est vraiment devenu à fleur de peau
et je bosse je souffre de voir comme ça
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui est
tellement sensible et malheureusement il
a une image qui ne correspond pas du
tout à ce qu'il est ce parce qu'ils
étaient avec quelqu'un de tellement
humain c'est un aveu elle est bien sûr
et vous aussi vous voulez dire oui c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui pendant un
moment on n'a rien montré et puis d'un
coup juste il n'est pas décédé
à étaler ses sentiments et d'un coup ça
sort et c'est vrai qu'on est tous
effrayés choqué comme pour liesse parce
que c'est incroyable et valérie le
disait ce sont des délits je sais qui
est par exemple a porté plainte plein de
fois et il est pas assez écoutés ils
sont pas assez écoutés a donc c'est ce
que faut il faut agir il faut ce mardi
daniel un journaliste mais oui au
journalisme et oui on te soutient
mathieu courage et oui c'est quand même
grave en 2009 c'est un délit il faut
pour vivre la moindre des vignes et je
suis d'accord avec le combat de mathieu
de liesse c'est notre combat à tous tous
les jours tout le temps voilà menton
combattants se dit plutôt bravo a envoyé
spécial aux équipes enfin et même fier
d'avoir avec nous merci d'y être et
mathieu gines j'ai une proposition à te
faire dormir chez vous est-ce que tu
devrais que je devienne son garde du
corps j'aurais dit oui oui attention
parce que c'est que je peux tout mais
houston je peux m'attacher à mon garde
du corps peut être beau kevin costner
mais alors juste entendre que les deux
ont subi ce que série qualité très
proche de match aussi je suis super émue
par ce qui se passe ce soir et mathieu
c'est vrai qu'avec l'image qui peut
refléter en fait celle inverse c'est
juste quelqu'un d'hyper sensible c'est
un amour et il est là pour moi aussi je
suis là pour lui je le pense pas tous
les soirs celui merci
[Applaudissements]